your second Golden Globe nomination  crazy how are you feeling right now I'm  Schmidt Singh  I'm excited the Hollywood Foreign Press  Association changed my life last year  like entirely I don't feel like I could  have ever asked for any more and so this  morning when I heard my name called I  fell to the kitchen floor and started  crying well then if you heard a little  bit about the Twitter mix-up that  happened this morning with the globe I  didn't hear anything until like recently  somebody sent me an article but oh who  cares who cares  America's lovely she's so beautiful and  such a prince a fantastic actress that  you know I shoot it if anybody I want to  get mixed up with it's her for sure so I  mean to me it's like about whatever  makes it we always make mix-ups  enlightenment